[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal nous sommes le
mercredi 24 novembre voici les titres de
cette édition
samedi 20 novembre marquer la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
adoptée en 1989 par l'onu la convention
fête ses 32 ans cette année où en est on
aujourd'hui le point dans ce journal
dans le cadre de la 10e édition de la
semaine de l'industrie des étudiants de
l'estaca se sont rendus au technocentre
renault de guyancourt objectif pour ces
futurs ingénieurs découvrir la
conception automobile
et puis à un mois de noël vous êtes
nombreux à avoir commencé vos achats
pour l'occasion quelles sont les
tendances 2021 en termes de cadeaux nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre deux
parents et deux grandes enseignes la
réponse dans cette édition
mais avant de développer ces titres le
verdict de la sphère de la sextape de
mathieu valbuena est tombée ce mercredi
24 novembre reconnu coupable de
complicité de délit de tentative de
chantage karim benzema a été condamné à
un an de prison avec sursis il devra
également s'acquitter d'une amende de 75
mille euros un jugement rendu par le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles
l'attaquant du real madrid devrait faire
appel les quatre autres prévenus ont
également été condamnés on reste sur une
page judiciaire avec l'interpellation ce
mardi 23 novembre de 13 militants
appartenant au mouvement d'ultra
d'ultra-droite recolonisation france ils
sont soupçonnés de vouloir constituer un
groupe armé ces derniers ont été placés
en garde à vue pour 48 heures ces
interpellations menées par un juge
d'instruction de marseille sont
intervenus dans toute la france
notamment dont les yvelines car parmi
eux se trouvait un colonel de
gendarmerie en poste dans le département
pendant les perquisitions conduites chez
les suspects des armes des gilets pare
balles et un exemplaire de mein kampf
ont été retrouvés l'enquète est dirigée
par le parquet de marseille
[Musique]
je vous le disais en titre
l'organisation des nations unies fête
ses 32 enfin la convention fête ses 32
ans la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant elle a pour but
d'assurer le droit à la vie à la santé
ou encore à l'éducation le but faire
entendre leur voix quel que soit
l'endroit dans le monde où il se trouve
et c'est dans ce cadre que les enfants
étaient invités à l'hôtel de ville de
montigny le bretonneux cet après-midi
pour fêter leurs droits mathilde francou
à s'est rendu sur place regarder une
journée pour sensibiliser aux nombreuses
injustices subies par les enfants en
france et dans le monde à montigny le
bretonneux les enfants étaient nombreux
ce mercredi 24 novembre à l'hôtel de
ville au programme des animations de
sensibilisation menées par les équipes
d'animation des accueils de loisirs que
du conseil municipal des jeunes comme
des plaques où les enfants pouvaient
dessiner ce que représente leur droit à
leurs yeux scellé droit que normalement
tous les enfants devraient avoir être
soigné avoir une nationalité
être coté être protégés avoir une
famille
avoir le droit de s'exprimer plus en
prendre d'aller à l'école tous les
enfants droit
bah de manger à leur faim et de boire la
tasse droit à une famille on a le droit
d'avoir une nationalité les enfants
pouvaient également planter des fleurs
aux couleurs de l'unicef et de
l'organisation des nations unies au pied
de l'arbre des droits de l'enfant y aura
donc ces trois lettres non convention
universelle des droits des enfants qui
ont être
je vais être fleuris aux couleurs de
l'onu et de l'unicef donc bleu et blanc
et pour avoir une trace visible des
droits des enfants soit armes des quiz
des mots mêlés ou encore un memory pour
en apprendre plus sur leurs droits un
enjeu important pour la ville de
montigny le bretonneux qui fait partie
du réseau villes des enfants depuis 2017
nous considérons à montigny que la
jeunesse est une richesse les richesses
importantes pour le pays pour l'avenir
et qu'on doit vraiment beaucoup investir
pour 7 pour pour nos enfants pour la
jeunesse une journée des droits de
l'enfant plus que jamais nécessaire
selon l'unicef la crise sanitaire fait
peser des menaces sur la santé la
sécurité et le bien-être et l'avenir des
enfants ces derniers ont vu leur
quotidien bouleversé par le virus avec
la fermeture des écoles les différents
confinement ou encore l'arrêt des
activités physiques ou de loisirs des
faits qui vont creuser davantage encore
des inégalités existantes
et pour continuer sur le sujet philippe
journée quand vous êtes avec nous ce
soir bonsoir vous êtes chargé de
l'engagement jeunes pour unicef yvelines
donc je le rappelle samedi 20 novembre
marquer la journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant est-ce que déjà on
peut revenir assure cette journée dans
les yvelines comment ça s'est passé
alors dans les yvelines massa s'est
passé dans plusieurs communes et
d'autant que c'est une multiplication de
d'actualité pour l'unicef 78 et pour
toutes les délégations départementales
de l'unicef parce que c'est là la
signature des conventions ville amie des
enfants les qu'est ce que ça veut dire
une ville amie des enfants mais ce sont
des villes qui ont qui signent un accord
à une convention avec
nice est de façon à permettre aux
enfants de mieux vivre dans dans les
villes de mettre en place des actions
spécialement à destination des jeunes
mais également ses villes nous aident à
travers d'aidés des forums si vous
voulez participative à faire mieux
comprendre les droits des enfants à
mieux les faire admettre par la
population à mieux les à ce qu'ils
devaient prennent véritablement corps et
c'est une nécessité absolue parce que on
peut se dire en 2021 ça fait 32 ans que
cette convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant qui a été adoptée je
vous le rappelle à l'unanimité de tous
les pays membres de l'onu cette
convention a une force de loi en théorie
dans tous ces pays qu'ils ont ils l'ont
ratifié la france l'a ratifié et dans
tous les textes de loi la convention est
prise et prises en compte donc moi c'est
très important de rappeler qu'elles
existent parce que tous les jours tous
les jours il y a des des exemples de
situations dans lesquelles mme à la
convention n'est pas appliqué les ponts
les enfants reste vulnérable tant au
plan santé au plan nutritionnel au plan
éducatif bien évidemment et puis il ya
un droit important qui a été mentionnée
par un enfant dans votre reportage à
montigny c'est un droit je dirais
essentiel mais auront l'oubli c'est le
droit à l'identité sans identité vous
n'existez pas un enfant n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dans le monde il ya 230
millions d'enfants qui n'ont pas
d'identité officielle qui n'existe pas
au vu de leur pays donc ils ne peuvent
pas en théorie sortir de le pays ne
peuvent pas avoir de carte d'identité
ils ne peuvent pas avoir de passeports
encore moins ils ne peuvent pas passer
d'examen parce que lorsque l'on passe un
examen emma au bord de la table on a
ça un justificatif de son identité qui
doit être présenté à ses enfants ne
peuvent pas passer des examens donc sont
exclues de l'éducation du nez d'une
éducation un petit peu plus poussée
encore à l'école primaire jusqu'au
certificat d'études on peut suivre
relativement mais bon après on est on
est totalement bloqué ils ne peuvent pas
se faire suivre à l'hôpital non plus
avec des systèmes de santé qui
permettrait de leur venir en aide
gratuitement ou à moindre coût pour
l'heure leurs parents donc c'est à
droite est tout à fait essentiel c'est
ce qu'on appelle ce que robert badinter
appelait les enfants fantômes on a
découvert cette appellation cette
situation la mise en avant dans les
années 80 mais elle perdure je vous dis
aujourd'hui encore 230 millions
d'enfants n'ont pas d'identité
officielle d enfance et des jaunes qui
jusqu'à 18 ans pour la convention selon
la convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant et il faut se battre et
aujourd'hui il ya un milliard de
personnes sur terre enfants et adultes
qui n'ont pas d'identité officielle donc
les des enfants sont fragiles il faut
les protéger c'est notre avenir elle
vous parlez de la convention justement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi cette convention quelle est sa
force juridique en fait mais comme je
les dis ça fort de la force juridique de
cette convention c'est formidable parce
qu'avant il y avait des ddd paroles
moralisatrices pour le bien-être des
enfants des lois
ddd discussions sur les droits des
enfants et s'établissent à n'avait pas
force de loi il n'y avait eu aucune
contrainte qui était suis aujourd'hui
cette convention a force de loi
normalement par exemple en france et
bien elle a été ratifiée en 1990 par la
france et tous les articles du code
pénal du code civil prennent en compte
ont ajusté les différents articles leurs
différents articles on avec cette
convention des droits de l'enfant ont eu
un article de loi aujourd'hui ne peut
pas aller à l'encontre de ce que d'une
convention une convention est supérieure
à la loi française à la limite
je voudrais parler avec vous aussi de la
crise sanitaire qu'on vit depuis un peu
plus d'un an et demi maintenant comment
cette crise impacte les enfants je pense
notamment l'a entendue dans dans le
reportage précédent à l'accès à
l'éducation avec la fermeture des écoles
et parfois l'impossibilité de suivre des
cours à distance alors bien évidemment
mais cela creuse le fossé enfin
finalement entre les enfants favorisés
et les enfants plus vulnérables alors en
france
on a vu des enfants qui n'ont pas
d'ordinateur qui ne pouvaient pas suivre
leur scolarité pendant les pendant la
crise sanitaire alors que les écoles
étaient fermées donc il ya des jeunes
ambassadeurs il ya des lunes et s'est
immobilisée entre autres avec d'autres
associations pour venir en aide à ces
enfants leur apporter par téléphone par
avoir un contact avec ses enfants leur
envoyer des d écriture des textes à lire
et c'est de façon à ce qu'il ne perd pas
l'école parce que lorsqu'un enfant perd
l'école lorsqu'il se disent cole arrive
c'est très dur de raccrocher pour
certains les plus vulnérables ont
beaucoup de mal à raccrocher après
à l'action éducative la déscolarisation
et est présente en france alors je ne
vous parle pas dans les pays pauvres ou
alors l'aller les moyens internet sont
sont vraiment très très très limité
massey ce sont des enfants qui sont
totalement déscolarisés qui ont été
totalement déscolarisés et qui ne vont
plus aller à l'école au jour
actuellement en 2020 l'unicef estime
estime qu'il y à 63 millions d'enfants
dans le monde qui ne vont pas à l'école
qui ne peuvent pas aller à l'école qui
ne vont pas à l'école plutôt qu'ils ne
vont pas à l'école mais demain vu la
crise vu l'arrêt le coup d'arrêt
l'éducation pour certains enfants vue
la crise sanitaire qui perdure et qui
reprend dans en occident eh bien on
estime qu' un nombre encore croissant
d'enfants va être disque la risée et
c'est terrible parce que l'éducation est
à la base de tous pour permettre aux
enfants de grandir et de s'épanouir
d'où le fait qu'il est important
d'honorer les droits des enfants chaque
année j'imagine avec cette journée
absolument donc c'est c'est très
important le levain le 20 novembre
marqué c'est une date historique dans
l'histoire du droit des enfants qui
cette année pour massa marque également
les 75 ans de l'unicef l'unicef c'est le
fonds des nations unies pour l'enfance
un fonds qui a été créée en 1946 au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
de façon à venir en aide au pays dévasté
par cette guerre de permettre aux
enfants de se reconstruire en quelque
sorte alors comment ce s'est passé dans
les yvelines cette cette célébration de
la de la convention d'aidé 32 ans de la
convention internationale des droits des
femmes plusieurs municipalités ont
éclairé leur hôtel de ville au blanc
bleu le 20 novembre le bleu c'est la
couleur de l'eau nuls la couleur de
l'unicef je citais il encourt andrésy
noisy le roi et est la ville de
carrières sous poissy dans laquelle je
me trouve aujourd'hui carrières sous
poissy qui va dans dans quelques minutes
signés avec michel mennella notre
présidente
une nouvelle charte ville amie des
enfants
tout comme l'on signait déjà versailles
montigny guyancourt ben et comme vont le
faire pendant quelques semaines de voir
dans les prochains mois aubergenville
noisy mon choisy le roi maure poids
rambouillet marly
conflans sainte honorine
ce sera le 10 défend le 10 décembre
actuellement sur les yvelines et c'est
assez extraordinaire nous sommes l'un
des départements les plus enclins
avec le système ville amie des enfants
il ya il y aura treize villes 14 villes
qui vont être ville amie des enfants
dans dans quelques semaines et c'est
formidable pour promouvoir les actions
de l'unicef pour promouvoir les marchés
de noël les stands parce que nous en
france on fait connaître du plaidoyer
pour le
pour la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant mais c'est aussi une
démarche de collecte de deux façons de
collecte d'argent de façon à permettre à
l'unicef va de remplir ses missions sur
le terrain dans dans des dans des pays
où est bien la situation est beaucoup
plus tragique beaucoup plus dramatique
qu'en france merci beaucoup philippe
journée qu'ont avoir été avec nous ce
soir je le rappelle vous êtes chargé de
l'engagement jeunes pour unicef yvelines
merci beaucoup et moi c'est moi qui vous
remercie justin merci
[Musique]
nous sommes en pleine semaine de
l'industrie une 10e édition qui se tient
du 22 au 28 novembre 2021 dans ce cadre
15 étudiants de l'estaca l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny le bretonneux
ont pu visiter le technocentre renault
de guyancourt
ils ont découvert le coeur de
l'ingénierie du groupe automobile le
reportage de nicolas d'andré les secrets
de la conception des enjoliveurs des
roues des véhicules renault c'est ce
qu'ont pu découvrir ces quinze étudiants
de l'estaca de montigny le bretonneux
ces futurs ingénieurs dans l'automobile
ont reçu des explications d'anthony
zamani farhi pilote composants
enjoliveurs l'objectif est aussi un peu
leur montrer qu est-ce que l'ingénierie
automobile et comment nous on apercevait
dans notre domaine on est dans un très
grand groupe et donc c'est très
important d'être organisée et le fait
d'être organisés nous permet d'être plus
efficaces et j'essaie des points que
vous les montrer pour eux parce que
c'est la particularité d'être rigoureux
d'entreprise c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel je crois que ça nous permet
d'avoir une vision sur
qu'est ce que le métier d'ingénieur
parce que quand on à l'école sceptre et
au final ça nous a permis de mieux
comprendre l'environnement de travail
chez renault pour les ingénieurs et
aussi de voir du coup tous leurs
processus de travail est vraiment déjà
dix mille personnes qui travaillent sur
le site plus cent vingt mille personnes
autour du monde qui vont pas pas grande
partie tous travailler sur un même
produit ce moment des changes s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la visite du
technocentre par ces étudiants de
l'école d'ingénieurs de montigny le
bretonneux un événement organisé durant
la semaine de l'industrie un rendez vous
incontournable pour l'estac a dans ses
relations avec les entreprises ça permet
pour eux de se projeter de pouvoir poser
des questions
un intervenant qui finalement est un peu
leur projection du futur
ça leur permet aussi de comprendre les
rouages de l'ingénierie de leur futur
métier découverte des futurs véhicules
du groupe renault des dernières
innovations technologiques dans le
secteur automobile cette visite du
technocentre a pu confirmer la vocation
de ces quinze étudiants de l'estaca
ce sera un nouvel établissement et
nouvelles filières dans le monde de
l'enseignement supérieur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'école
supérieure d'agriculture va s'implanter
sur le territoire pour la rentrée
scolaire 2022 une conférence au ski cub
s'est tenue ce mercredi matin pour
annoncer ce projet une école basée
historiquement à angers élargit sa
présence en s'installant en région
parisienne elle sera située à guyancourt
et proposera deux cursus de formation
ingénieur et bachelor agro écologie et
systèmes alimentaires on écoute à ce
propos le président de lézat et le
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines est déléguée à
l'enseignement supérieur au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
landry nous allons accueillir au début
une centaine de jeunes dans ce bâtiment
pour monter rapidement à 300 dans les
deux ans et les débouchés de l'oeil
façon très très diverses on a un peu
moins de entre 5 et 10 % de jeunes qui
reprennent une exploitation à la sortie
de l'école et les toutes les autres
jeunes vont vers soi les organisations
agricoles soit vers la recherche soit
vers l'agroalimentaire et là d'un gros
un gros un effectif important qui va
vers les entreprises agroalimentaires
une école comme la comme les as et de
l'agriculture c'est de l'agroalimentaire
c'est du développement durable durable
donc c'est un très large panel un
trailer pas neige panel au niveau
innovation qui s'insère parfaitement
dans un territoire comme saint quentin
en yvelines en politique à présent dans
le cadre des élections présidentielles à
venir une réunion publique était
organisée ce mardi 23 novembre à
houilles le but réunir les comités de
soutien yves binois emmanuel macron
l'événement s'est tenu salle rené cassin
en présence de la ministre naji et des
maires du territoire
[Musique]
dunes d'espoir c'est une association
yvelinoise elle donne l'occasion à des
personnes à mobilité réduite de pouvoir
participer à des courses ou des
randonnées au moyen d'une joëlette c'est
un fauteuil monoroue accompagné de
brancards permettant de faire rouler ou
de porter longin et dimanche 14 novembre
une course s'est déroulée à vélizy hugo
et gabriel pilote de joëlettes et ont
participé le reportage de mathilde
francou essenine charles hugo et gabriel
se prépare à partir pour une course de
10 km mais ils ne sont pas seuls en
situation de handicap ils ont besoin de
leurs coéquipiers pour pousser leurs
joëlette sorte de fauteuil roulant tout
terrain et janet est donc un engin à une
roue qui permet d'emmener des jeunes à
mobilité réduite sur les routes dans les
forêts dans les montagnes dans les
collines il faut une personne qui y
pousse une personne qui tire et ont fait
avancer la violette
et on se relaye entre coureurs ont
participé à ces événements sportifs on
se dépasse ans et de manière collective
ça me paraît être la meilleure manière
pour apprendre à vivre ensemble pour lui
c'est super intéressant parce que comme
sa maladie en soi c'est un manque
d'énergie il sait qu'il peut pas faire
de sport qui peut pas courir qui peut
pas voilà des déployer de force dans
l'activité sportive il est conscient que
le fait qu'on court pour lui ou concours
avec lui ou qu'on fasse du vélo ça
apporte de l'énergie et ses apports de
l'énergie bas financière et physique et
mentale ses membres habitués ou
débutants de l'association dunes
d'espoir permettent à des personnes
handicapées de faire des courses
habituellement réservé aux valides 35 kg
a poussé c'est physique mais ses
accompagnateurs donc un challenge faire
sourire le pilote d'un effort collectif
puisque on se relaie autour de la
joélette avec le pilote et qu'on arrive
on part ensemble en arrivant semble donc
c'est ça qui fait la force de cet
exercice dit que si un dimanche matin on
doit se lever pour aller courir autant
de le faire
deux façons de façon joyeuse souvent
quand y'a pas le soleil on se dit que le
soleil il est là et dans nos coeurs dans
le coeur des enfants et dans leur
sourire delà des sensations qui plaisent
aux pilotes montant de l'aide
le sourire du jeune vous voyez le
sourire du jeune de nos l'énergie à tous
les coureurs on chante on crie on fait
les fous ils étaient super contents il
ya le fait de faire partie d'un groupe
vous faites on voit elle est parce qu il
court il ya tout le monde qui dit aller
hugo
c'est beaucoup de bonheur une activité
de partage pour tous le monde grâce à la
joélette et qui se déroulent tout au
long de l'année dans les yvelines et en
dehors avec dunes d'espoir
et on termine ce journal avec les fêtes
de fin d'année qui approchent des
grandes enseignes se sont parés de leurs
plus belles décorations et les français
ont commencé à faire leurs cadeaux mais
quelles sont les tendances sous le sapin
à la proche de noël qu'est-ce qui fait
rêver petits et grands cette année matt
hill francou a mené l'enquêté regardez
après un noël marqué l'année dernière
par la crise sanitaire la course aux
cadeaux et aux jouets est bel et bien
lancée malgré quelques ruptures de stock
la pénurie due à des retards de
livraison n'a finalement pas eu lieu et
selon l'enseigne king jouet 56 % des
parents ont déjà commencé leur premier
achat on n'a aucune contrainte cette
année particulière duo kobe de comme
l'année dernière chose comme ça donc
cette année les gens sont au rendez vous
la magie rendez vous donc le tour est
passé parfaitement cette année sous le
sapin les héros reprennent du service
dans les grandes tendances on retrouve
les jouets harry potter marvel ou encore
pas de patrouille qui connaît un très
grand succès auprès des tout-petits
depuis la sortie du film cet été au
cinéma alors pendant un stoner en avait
créé dangereux car on savait trouver
tous les produits harry potter sera en
fête les 25 ans de l'univers vous allez
avoir tout ce qui est pas patrouille les
sens pas trop ils y sont sont fortes en
fait de manière générale cette année
tous les super héros avec trish immorale
qui sortent lors des différents
confinement les familles ont passé plus
de temps à jouer ensemble les jeux de
société et les puzzles se retrouve donc
en bonne place dans les rayons tout
comme les jouets éthique et
éco-responsable qui gagne du terrain
chaque année je sais pas on regarde un
peu partout quelque chose de kate en
bois qui en a tout l'air qui ne contient
pas de et des produits nocifs et d'un
pad panther et tout ça et malgré la
hausse des prix des matières premières à
cause du transport les jouets ne seront
pas tous impacté de la même façon une
situation qui profite aux jouets
français ils représentent 15% des ventes
globales depuis le début de l'année on
retrouve par exemple l'indémodable
sophie la girafe décliné en peluches
doudous ou jouer ludique
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi très bonne soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]